цей звук сирен знає кожен українець це
означає пора йти в безпечне місце під
землею коли почалося повномасштабне
вторгнення шукати прихистку під час
тривоги для підприємств означало
припинення роботи та рік потому
виробництво на цьому металургійному
заводі продовжує працювати незважаючи ні
на що завдяки цьому імпровізованому
пункту управління люди тут у
бомбосховищі можуть підтримувати
автономну роботу машин наші ребята наші
хлопці зуміли за місяць впровадити
систему дистанційного керування
завантаженням ось цих бункерів
щоб повністю виключити людський фактор
Таким чином спочатку квітня минулого
року ми вже працюємо під час повітряних
тривог в автоматичному режимі
в
йде у захисну споруду там вмикається
система дистанційного керування
ми можемо звідти керувати завантаженням
бункерів та опалювальною машиною
бункер забезпечений усім необхідним їжею
водою інтернет та генераторами керівник
показує запаси у разі потреби каже він
вони могли б прожити на цих продуктах
кілька днів або навіть тижнів і хоч цей
завод не постраждав ризики все ще
реальні російські війська досі
знаходяться менше ніж за 100 кілометрів
від нього
під час війни нехтувати цим не можна
ніхто не знає що буде завтра вони мають
бути у нас підготовлені функціональні та
забезпечені запасами І дай боже щоб нам
це не знадобилося
але іншим українським компаніям
пощастило менше дві російські ракети з
різницею кілька днів влучили у це
підприємство в Дніпрі вбивши двох людей
якби Перший удар не припав на вихідні ця
цифра ймовірно була б набагато вищою
світ
ракета може прилетіти в будь-який час
сили будь-яке місце будь-який будинок чи
будь-яке приміщення я тут вперше бачив
лише фотографії я не хотів приїжджати бо
пам'ятаю техніку зусилля які ми
витратили на все це
Ось так Це виглядає коли на твій завод
приходить русский міри через вибухи
конструкції отримали стільки пошкоджень
що ними більше неможливо користуватися
тільки зносити А це ще одна фабрика
В'ячеслава Вона все ще працює але
бореться з наслідками російських атак на
енергосистему України тут виготовляють
преси для промисловості та обладнання
для машинобудування
кілька місяців коли звучить повітряна
тривога енергетична компанія вимикає всю
електрику це буває непередбачувано
щоразу коли це відбувається ми втрачаємо
близько 40-50 тисяч євро за одну хвилину
матеріал всередині не може втрачати
температуру коли він втрачає температуру
він тріскається і ламається
генератори допомагають у роботі тепер
працівники можуть запобігти
неконтрольованим відключенням вигравши
час для подачі природного газу який
стабілізує температуру до відновлення
електроенергії Якщо раніше у них
випадали Цілі дні виробництва щоразу
коли вимикалася електроенергія То тепер
це лічені години та електроенергія не
єдина проблема з якою вони мають справу
український фірми які працюють
незважаючи ні на що все частіше
зіштовхується з тим що багато клієнтів у
Європі не хочуть з ними співпрацювати
вони бояться що війна завадить їхнім
українським постачальникам доставляти
товари звичайно усі втомлені та
виснажені іноді їм хочеться заплющити
очі уявити що це все лише погане сон Але
ми не заплющуємо очі та продовжуємо
боротися усі борються на своєму місці
моя робота полягає у тому щоб
переконатися що заводи працюють і люди
отримують зарплати А я можу допомогти
бійцям купити спорядження
зараз усе що ми могли реінвестувати ми
витрачаємо на закупівлю безпілотників
машин спеціального обладнання
крім того через повномасштабне
вторгнення поменшили клієнтів у середині
країни
ще один наш продукт спеціальні помпи
які використовуються на великих заводах
це було 60% наших продажів у цьому
регіоні
Зараз ми шукаємо нові ринки збуту
спочатку в Україні ми виробляли цю
продукцію для багатьох портів і для
багатьох великих заводів
тепер попит з Маріуполя нульовий попит з
боку порті чорноморського регіону десь
20% у порівнянні з довоєнним часом
але не кожен бізнес може впоратися з
такими ударами як цей В'ячеслав
розповідає Що щонайменше чверть його
конкурентів уже збанкрутували і
банкрутства продовжується за словами
керівника військової адміністрації
Кривого Рогу Олександра вілкула через
блокаду Росією українських портів великі
гірничо-металургійні підприємства
працюють на мінімум можливостей великі
підприємства металургійного комплексу
гірничого комплексу зараз працюють на
10-20%. реально
задля того щоб працювала важка
промисловість нам треба
доступ до чорноморських портів тобто до
можливості експортувати продукцію
електроенергія - це є проблема але
головна проблема це парти це експорт
зараз там працює фрезерновий коридор а
інший види продукції там вивозити
неможливо тому звичайно цей продукт
ніхто не виготовляє і підприємство
працює на 10-20%. попри всю стійкість
економіка України все ще перебуває у
вільному падінні через що країна та
армія дедалі більше залежить від
міжнародної підтримки